let's talk about this girls wasting
their 20s okay and how old are you by
the way i'm 25. you're 25 yes you are 27
20 coco 31 31 okay so you guys are in
mid 20s early 30s
um
i've been very vocal about this i'll as
a guy waste your 20s as much as you'd
like your 20s are your time to [ __ ] up
make mistakes do stupid stuff date the
wrong girl
as a guy
it's you're able to do that as a girl
you can do that in your early 20s you do
not want to do that in your late 20s
okay
um let's talk about that why is it
important for a girl to actually
not waste their 20s well your value
decreases as a woman the older you get
and your opportunity to give a man
children um it's less and less the older
you get yeah you can have
ivf but most guys don't want to spend
like what is it 30k
16k 16k yeah work most of the time yeah
so i mean if a guy can pick you know a
35 year old woman or a 25 year old woman
he's going to pick the 25 year old woman
you think so yeah why because of the
ability to be for fertile yeah partially
and like men
they surveyed men between the ages of
like 20 and 80 and all of them
prefer girls around the age of 22 23.
yeah this is what rolo was saying sexual
the sexual marketplace so um i mean i
think there's other sexual market value
i don't want to mess that up yeah i mean
i think there's other things that come
into play but i think men when it comes
to building a family and you also have
the issue of you know the more
relationships that a girl has been and
the more traumatized she's going to be
the more she the more access she has to
complain about yeah and that just
happens the older you get well let me
let me actually give you a different
side of the coin because i remember you
were very um
open about this you said you are so much
better of a woman as a female as a
girlfriend at 30 31 as you were at 24.
yeah explain why
i feel in your 20s you're just you're
starting to learn who you are and you
see what you like when you dislike and
i think that in your 20s
you shouldn't be dating somebody
like if you're 21 22 you should not be
in a relationship for like five years
i think you should if it happens great
good for you but i think that you should
explore who you are as a person and by
that you can also date multiple guys so
you can see what you like when you're
disliked so you think that a woman who's
21 22 she gets out of college she should
go through her whole face
never said that i said it you did
no i never said you should go through a
whole face you said date multiple guys
so i did not say it has to be oh but we
know what i mean i think you should
live your life
and see who you are so then later on
when you're ready and when you're
emotionally mature because when you're
21 2 you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on at least i didn't i mean i
moved here when i was 22 so
in this past eight nine years i changed
a lot because i learned who i am
what if i got married to a guy that i
was dating when i was 21 22 because my
goal in life was to get married i would
i didn't know who i am okay so how can
you get married
and be with somebody
but you're not even
sure who you are yeah so how do you guys
grapple with that because you're
basically saying the exact opposite
thing that she's saying so would you
guys engage and have this i don't
understand what that means you don't
know who you are you're trying to figure
out what you want in life like i just
i've always known who i am well not
everybody is the same
i just don't get what girls mean when
they say that
what what is it like they want to just i
mean i get it they kind of want to
figure it out
so
i think there's some truth to some of
the things that coco says because one of
the reasons that pearl probably knew who
she was when she knew it is because you
had a really great parent so you're
doing a well-rounded two-parent
household but i i actually don't agree
entirely with you know the red pill
about oh go ahead and get out there and
get a husband as young as you can i
think you have the most leverage in your
youth i can agree to that i think you
have a lot more options at 20 to 24 but
i can say that i don't think most
american women know themselves until
they're 24 and then i mean even after
that like there's a lot of narcissistic
clueless women running around out here
and they're going to be a liability the
problem is is that they let the
narcissism run its way into their 30s
and they're surprised like why didn't my
life work out it's because you need a
reality check and that's i think that's
why pearl and i have the content that we
do to just give women a heads up like
hey like your 20s you could really be on
a mission so you want to talk about oh i
want a career and i want a husband okay
fabulous amazing set it up by 24. if
you're hard charging and you're an
intelligent woman you can set it up for
at 24 and then you can pursue dating
full force can you define just set it up
by 24 have a foundation of platform you
can have a bachelor's degree if you want
you can have internships you can have
connections networking whatever you need
as a foundation so that way
you've done most of the hard work and
you can still take on that relationship
and continue to do harder work in your
career if you need
[Music]